it's wednesday the 29th of [ __ ]
july what have you done
all month let's spark up a number out of
respect
greetings from podcastville the church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by
draftkings listen whether you like it or
not
you're gambling your life right now just
to go down to the store for the corner
milk you're gambling with your life just
to go down
just when you leave the [ __ ] house so
why not put a little bit of money
on draftkings like tomorrow thursday you
got the nba is back
live from disney world in the bubble how
many that's what we gotta bet on how
many people are gonna escape from the
[ __ ] bubble that's the bet
but tomorrow night you got the clippers
versus the lakers
and the pelicans versus the jazz what
we're gonna do here
at draftkings to celebrate is give you
25 bucks
joey howe place a 25 bet on which team
will be crowned champion
at the end of the nba season do it
before tip off tomorrow
and draftkings will give you a 24-hour
bet to use
on the first two games in the season not
to mention
new users get a bonus of up to a
thousand dollars
just for showing up so to get it on the
action download draftkings
sportsbook now and use code church
c-h-u-r-c-h
plus for limited time just for the
church family
all new users get a sign up bonus of the
g note larue that's a thousand
that's a [ __ ] ten thousand [ __ ]
duckets
whatever you want to call it rubles i
don't give a [ __ ] that's
cash [ __ ] listen you get a thousand
dollars
a grand when you get draftking
sportsbook app
and use code church download the app
only at draftking sportsbook and here's
the part
the lawyers make me say you know these
[ __ ] lawyers you got to do this [ __ ]
you got to be 21 and you got to be in
new jersey indiana
or pennsylvania only deposit bonus
requires a 25 times play through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details listen you got a
gambling problem
there's help for you you call 1-800
gambler
or if you're indianapolis indiana you
call 1-809 with it
you tell them what joey sent you but if
you don't have a gambling problem
get the draftkings sportsbook app and
let's [ __ ] get down
let's use code church c-h-u-r-c-h
take this [ __ ] mule lee
how long does this take here what's
going on
welcome to church
[Applause]
okay quickly's in studio finally she got
over the [ __ ] uh
she got over the herpes it was a long
three months in the hospital a couple
transfusions
and they then they gave her like [ __ ]
uh charlie sheen blood by mistake and
that
cured really [ __ ] it up that was
curious beautiful
i do thank you man the hair looks nice
really thank you i'm happy i can tell
you got a boyfriend you can
i could tell it's because i post
different i haven't been posting as much
it's weird having to think about
somebody else you know
i just yeah it's weird also saying i
have a boyfriend i've never really
admitted it
completely i say like oh that i'm seeing
this guy but yeah how long you been with
him now
actually it's so funny we like we met
years ago but we didn't
connect at all i wasn't really in
honestly i thought he was too nice for
me
like he has a very nice reputation and i
thought he'd be too straight edge
and uh but then i don't know we started
like dm'ing a little
and it was right before quarantine we
really started talking a lot
i actually was kind of pitching a
project to him which is hilarious like i
wasn't interested
he wasn't flirting and i wasn't flirting
we were just talking business
and then uh the project kind of fell
through
but then we just kept talking and then i
was lonely during quarantine
and i think i posted something like uh
hey i'm like bummed out tonight somebody
cheer me up and he texts me and was like
can i come to la and
take you out to dinner and that's how it
started that was like at the beginning
of quarantine and then
like quarantine where the [ __ ] did he
take you to dinner well he just bought
we just post made it but we didn't like
hook up
that right away or anything like that
that's what's weird about this
quarantine
is that we ended up facetiming like
every day
for hours so you i got to know him
better than i've ever gotten to know any
guy i've dated
before i slept with him definitely but
even you know
it's like we became friends really and i
know and here's what's different i knew
i liked him because i didn't send him
any hot photos
i didn't flirt like there was no like
sex thing i wouldn't i was like
bashful it was so weird
like you played your cards right i
didn't mean to i just he's such a nice
guy
that i'd like like i was actually
worried
that when we had sex it would be too
nice
i even told him that like once we
started to really
because we kind of knew we'd be together
before we even
had sex how we is love it's so [ __ ]
weird
it's so weird i did a whole podcast on
it how
you live your life you hook up with
people you think you're not doing
something else and you walk into a
laundromat
some girl looks at you you say hello
yeah next thing you're going for coffee
next thing you know
you're going for dinner she knows
somebody you know you go to the same
acting class
yeah bam you were like [ __ ] i've been
single for nine months i haven't gotten
late in 14 months
yeah i've never had that but yeah dog
if you listen to this podcast we've all
gone on
dry streaks yeah that you start
questioning
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like
yeah i went on one from
august of 84 to july of 85.
i love that you know the exact oh you
know by the day
nine months of celibacy nine months of
on purpose no no i was just
just getting those wow you know you
gotta suck a thousand dicks to find the
prince
that's true that's true you know you
gotta go you gotta kiss a thousand frogs
well you don't you gotta suck
i just tweeted that we're just trying to
find the best dick that's
so true man some of them taste like
hummus something that tastes like
shoehorns
i mean you know i like the guy but his
dick tastes like a shoehorn i haven't
had a shoehorn dick but i do have to say
that that is one thing during the last
six months
there were a few before this guy i went
on a dating streak where i kept dating
guys that were like
progressively worse like you would have
been so disappointed
in me like they were i thought i was
getting better yeah last time i saw you
were no one with no miss america
no mr america yeah you were trying to
shirt cut off he stunk like onions i was
yeah you brought him up to me and i'm
like get this get away from me that's
hilarious i don't even remember who it
was
he had a million twitter followers i'm
like i don't give a [ __ ] he's got
oh that guy that's following him his
[ __ ] leprosy
that's what's following that guy's sting
i forgot about that's what i was gonna
say yeah i'm like what the
[ __ ] but dudes don't let me ask you can
i ask you a question i don't want to get
dirty with you
but oh do it when you shower both you
guys
when you wash your dick and your balls
do you wash
under your balls absolutely like well
all the way under the balls pick them up
on them scrub it
i pull the skin back on the helmet i
polish out cause sometimes you get that
goo around the helmet
and it sticks to women's mouth if you're
[ __ ] non-jewish and you pull your
skin back
you get that little [ __ ] helmet jizz
i've never seen it sometimes i got a
little piece of toilet paper stuck in
there or something
i'm uncircumcised so how are you
uncircumcised
listen don't ask questions i pull the
dick back i scrub it good then i have a
special loofah
a dick loofah just for my [ __ ] oh
yeah you got to
get the special loofah and i cut but
i've eaten plenty of [ __ ] to see
when an [ __ ] has
had road damage i've seen [ __ ] that
have not
they smell good but they've had room
you've got to get in
so what i do is i never wanted that you
got to get the loofah
it's like three quarters of your finger
and you scrub that inside you get all
that
weight molecules wait wait wait wait
wait what's the loofah that you're using
is it like shaped like a finger no i cut
it
you cut it like i said i'm thinking of
putting it on the marker but you put it
on your finger
i didn't know you put it on your finger
[ __ ] it's like a puppet it's an
[ __ ] puppy boil it to get all the
[ __ ] germs off it like i turned the
water really hot
you pour it dry and i let it sit you
gotta take care of your [ __ ] [ __ ]
health is number one
i agree i started buying those ear
syringe things yeah
to use down there yeah animals and [ __ ]
because my gay friend
i thought it was enough to just scrub in
there no
not enough again gay guys they don't
[ __ ] around no they know what
if you want info on [ __ ] you put
your gay side aside they'll
oh my god there was a guy behind me he
was starting to shake even with the mask
on
i would have blown dr fauci right off
the [ __ ] chair he would have quit he
would have said in all my scientific
life
there's probably never smoke anything
like this
this smells worse than human it seems
like you ate the bat that killed the
wuhan mat
yeah i have to say i read that you
tweeted about it and when i read oh my
god
i can't wait i couldn't wait to run back
to the car because it was
i had to run away from the fart and then
when i got in the car i was trying to
get into the car
and i put my mask on it disappeared you
could see like a little covered dust
there was some mexican lady like looking
around like something happened
oh my god that's how i know that you
love me because i've only
heard you fart once do you know that
once in this room
one time in our whole friendship you've
never farted and some people you don't
want to fly around because you might
lose them
on me everybody farts around no one no
one else has ever farted around me
yes they do you just bring it out of me
i look at you and i feel like fun
i'm terrified of farting in front of
people yeah especially
any guy like really even if i don't like
him even if i'm not
like i'm just afraid that they'll never
want to [ __ ] me ever
again eventually it's funny once you
fought in front of a man
it's all over that means that means i
[ __ ] you in the ass
i came on your eyeballs that means i met
your mother your father your grandfather
your [ __ ] sister the one that's
missing a leg she lost the vietnam
you know what's that all once you got
everybody under control
a woman will [ __ ] cut a fart one
night during some [ __ ] it's not our
fault because once you've been in the
butt
hole you stretch it out it's just air
passing we're not used to
i don't do anal unless i'm in love love
love
like ever so i'm not used to having a
stretched out butthole
2500 what does that mean 2500 for the
[ __ ] no
i don't know not worth it i got a guy in
sherman oaks he's looking for [ __ ]
25 grand i would think about it
one pop you go home he gives you a
little swab with a smoothie
it's not worth it it's like giving blood
at the american red
it's nice they give you cross little
badge it's not even close
do you cookie after two they give you if
you faint some orange juice and a
snickerdoodle
if you're faint they [ __ ] you know
whatever i don't think man i don't know
i
that really scares me ain't all freaks
me out because of the whole
you know but as a man let me tell you
what the problem is with angel
tell me please to me to me
i'm gonna tell you how it worked for me
just so you know
you know as i was you you didn't learn
sex education in school
you learned sex education from gorillas
when i was growing up
yeah those guys that are older than me
were gorillas and they're like wait do
you [ __ ] them in the ass
that's the whole thing and i'm like
really so i don't know
it took me years to finally like ask
somebody
i'm not going to tell you who you don't
know who was anyway
i got to tell you something for it was
like smoking crack
it was so good no it's okay but it's
just too much work
unless you get [ __ ] in the ass on a
regular
it's too much work i got a little bit
and then put it in and then
you're holding my thighs with your hands
just a little bit a little oh no no stop
right there yeah stop right there i
might [ __ ]
i might just [ __ ] once they tell you
after [ __ ] then you have to start
pounding their ass
and playing with that little monkey you
get that clinton you're working like a
little [ __ ] like a like a like a
squeegee boy you just keep
that monkey and you keep pounding that
ass and a woman's actually suffering
not always suffering but she's making
weird noises that you wouldn't [ __ ]
you're either really suffering or it
feels awesome but it's hard to tell the
difference from the sound
if you've got two fingers in your [ __ ]
and i'm working and i'm pulling your
hair
i'm creating diversions it's like i'm
throwing a bomb over there yeah
that's the key that is the key when you
[ __ ] somebody in the ass you gotta you
just [ __ ] them in the air no like you
like it baby
oh yeah i love it i grew up all it was
in my high school yearbook
i can't wait to get [ __ ] in the ass
nobody likes getting [ __ ] on the air
it's true no you like it but here's the
problem if a girl lets you [ __ ] her in
the ass without lube and tells you it
feels good she's lying
like it does not feel good if a guy puts
even like two or three fingers in there
without lube it doesn't feel you have to
lube it
you have to i didn't know this i she
lubed it
yeah put it in it was drama and then you
come and the [ __ ] comes out like
chocolate milk like it's like like you
who like light chocolate milk
because they're mixed up with some ass
that was in there and at the end of the
night that goes was this all worth it
like she came on there was no eye
contact for an hour
you know was it really worth [ __ ]
somebody in the ass
never really did it unless a woman said
stick it in there [ __ ] big boy
interesting then you give them a stab in
the ass and again it wasn't
my main thing yeah i'd rather lick your
ass and finger you and play with you
and then pop it into your [ __ ] and then
mutt the nut
pull it out slap it into your mouth you
could taste that [ __ ]
yeah hot jizz in your mouth that's a
party women love that
that's and they'll suck it dry and then
they'll start all over again
so that [ __ ] is back at the tension you
flip them over
and you take boogie woogie to town
no but you're totally right honestly the
problem is that ass is limiting
because once it's in there you can't put
it anywhere else safely
oh no i sound like such a pretty girl i
love you to death you're my girl
i put it in your ass i'm popping it
after i come put it in your mouth
you're full you're tasting what i'm
tasting you can't do that who said
wait how are you tasting how are you
tasting your tongue isn't in as deep as
your dick
right you're not tasting what's on the
end of your dick not me you
not me you're the one that wanted to ask
you taste it you said you're tasting
what i'm tasting
no no no no no i tasted your [ __ ] i
licked it from behind
like you tasted the edge now i [ __ ] in
there and now i'm popping it out
it's halfway at attention no and you
gotta pop it in your mouth
like a chocolate bar i mean i'm scared
that's how you get covered
no you don't yeah no you don't that
that's that's how you avoid
listen that's how you avoid coconut i
can have chinese i gotta have 20 chinese
people cough on me
i could eat an [ __ ] no covert it
disintegrates it breaks down the barrier
it goes into your throat and it just
bubbles like i
presume it's like it's like putting
[ __ ] uh
[ __ ] juice is like putting uh
emergency
what's that stuff you put on peroxide
bubbles it just bubbles out of your ass
you see it
you wipe it and there's the covet that's
it nobody knows that it's so gross
but i don't know it's just all free butt
stuff just
freaks me out i haven't banged somebody
in the ass in 30 years
well so it's been since about the 90s
when i lived in boulder
that was the last time the 90s yeah i
lived in boulder holy [ __ ] that's when i
you know
that's when i was doing coke to the
level where women tell you
like the exorcist put it in my ass you
know you're like really
i need this and then i heard then i had
a friend of mine
i didn't tell him about my experiences
but he was telling me that
he [ __ ] the girl and he asked for man
she [ __ ] on his bed
it happened you could stop [ __ ] oh
i've never had that that's when listen
that's what i
that's when i stab you i put the blanket
around you i put
a chill around like a burrito i take
that [ __ ] and i put on your fingerprints
so i can't identify you
and i drop you off over one off the 170
up there
oh joe you can't [ __ ] on my bed that's
disrespectful i mean
even jesus will kill you i don't think
that's true actually i think jesus will
forgive you you can't [ __ ] on a man's
butt i heard that this chick
took a tremendous [ __ ] really as soon as
he took he
was banging something and his dick was
getting smaller
and finally just she's just saw
something
getting smaller no [ __ ] he's like what's
going on and she's like oh my god
that dick made my ass wanna [ __ ] i don't
know so wait
wait so why is it better to be on your
dick than on your bed i'd rather have it
on my bed than on my dick
no way what are you talking about you're
getting ready you want somebody to drop
a turret on your bed no but i don't want
it to be on my body
but your body you can wash easily you're
going to throw away that sheet or throw
burn that bed to the ground my dick is
always gonna be my dick
you're gonna that night change all the
sheets after you [ __ ] girl you haven't
even
have you even eaten an ass yet no well
kind of kinda
i did look at with george oh that's
right strip club i forgot
he sucked the cork which isn't the same
that's what i'm saying
it's better you don't get the whole
flavor oh yeah you got to put it in your
mouth and true what you really said
like the gum breaker she said she had
her butt plugged in on stage
that's it you didn't even so you didn't
eat an ass you licked the butt i looked
around in the bar yeah
there was it was an area i i still don't
i'm so disappointed that we've gone
through a whole quarantine and you
haven't eaten one ass
you believe this no like honestly he has
not not he didn't gain weight
he's just backed up with sperm he's
backed up with sperm he gained 60 pounds
of sperm
lee what the [ __ ] have you [ __ ] her in
question no no no
no and i beg them every day call this
one call that one call motion
you got to call three a day and
eventually you're trying to crack you
don't trust don't you trust
okay what's gonna happen to you you get
covered you're gonna go down for four
days and you'll be all right
i don't know i mean his health isn't
like he takes a hit of a drink
imagine him on facetime i'm telling you
i'm gonna be all right
i'll be back in three
they days him with a ventilator and
another line coming in from in and out
burger
i mean [ __ ] just little shakes and
stuff honestly this is the easiest time
to get laid
in history begging them to pull the
trigger first of all
you told me you'd kill me if i got
covered that's an expression
i'm not gonna kill you i'm poisoning you
at the hospital and they'll pull it as
cold but i'll shoot this
chemical i got that your toe if you get
kovic call me because i just want to get
it over with wouldn't that be great to
just have it and then you
no you can get it again are you sure yes
how do they know
because people have gotten it twice they
have yeah people have gotten it twice
i don't know that you don't want to talk
to those people ever again if you know
somebody twice
you take that [ __ ] out of your
phone and you put covet block on
it with two syringes and when he calls
the call goes directly to the coconut
i haven't even opened tinder i haven't
done [ __ ] are you sure this is true that
people have gotten covered twice
are you sure there's people saying it i
feel like
i don't know what's true and what's not
because there's so it's like only been
around for
not even a year right and like there's
so many stories and
every news outlet reports something
different and i don't know what's
political and what's real like i'm not
i'm not questioning it i have no [ __ ]
idea all i know is this
kate all i know is if somebody was to
have it yeah you should have got it
i should have it you've been to vegas i
should have it nashville yup phoenix
minneapolis minneapolis
totally you went around so i don't know
how you protected yourself i agree
the alcohol has a uh a health issue
the alcohol once you said phoenix now
you gotta open it a little bit more
i really i think it's the air i think if
you're in open air spaces you're okay
but she wasn't an open air space she was
inside in phoenix
i mean she was inside a minneapolis
i might have had it though like that's
what i can't figure out because okay
here's what i don't get
like do you remember around like
february
right before this a lot of comics were
sick like i had to cancel a show
i remember monarch canceled a show we
had tons of people
call in fact the last night i was the
comedy store that you were there
somebody cancelled because dean del rey
went up
so he came in and went up so like i kind
of wondered if cause
how did we not all catch it we all share
microphones
microphone
i mean it started months before in china
so yeah some people
you can get a test to see if you have
the antibodies i know but it's 50
they say so you don't even know i took
the blood test and they said that
the blood test is good but you got to
swab the mouth and the nose because
they're respiratory symptoms
yeah i did the nose when it wasn't that
bad it was annoying but
yeah i wanted my thing is just like
it's so weird traveling because i
wouldn't do it
literally but here's what's weird is
like we live in california i go to
phoenix
i drove because they asked me to they
were like don't fly
because of covet so i drove the whole
way across california you can't pee
there's no public restrooms in
california at gas stations
truck stops anywhere denny's you can get
food
you can't pee so i had to keep peeing in
parking lots
car washes wherever i could find then
you get to phoenix
and like every bar is packed the pools
are it's like
it doesn't make sense because
everything's different or even airport
to airport
some airports are hand dryers some are
paper towels like i don't understand
what
how are the airports looking today i
mean
my last two flights were half full maybe
a little less than half like
uh most people didn't have a whole row
but they had like a seat between masks
you gotta wear one to get on you don't
have to keep it on but most people do
but then they still serve
water and chips no real food or drinks
no alcohol
really yeah that's what's so bizarre is
like
you can take your mask off to drink
water but not alcohol
so like in some ways okay this i'm not
like this is like
not to be a conspiracy theorist but i
kind of feel like all the billionaires
are going to come out way on top because
you go to any restaurant
anywhere in the country right now and
they give you a qr code to scan for a
menu
and they say it's so you don't have to
touch it but then you can order online
so it's like they're going to cut
servers and then they're not serving
anything on the planes because covet but
they'll give you water and chips like
what's the [ __ ] difference between
a drink and a cup of water it's like
it feels like they're trying to get rid
of employees
like if that's how i feel i really feel
like the people at the top like the top
not even one percent like half of one
percent will be even richer
and everybody else will be unemployed i
have a buddy who does
it's called distressed restructuring
that's what he calls it and he said like
75 of the small businesses aren't going
to reopen they told me that at the
beginning
and all the everything everything that's
staying open are the main
the big chains everything else is closed
all the small things
yeah and i mean i'm not like don't get
me wrong like i
my mom has lupus and my whole family is
like autoimmune
pretty much so i can't go home my mom
would die
if she got it but like so i know it's a
real thing
but it's just it it doesn't make any
sense how it's like
different from state it just makes no
sense it's political on
both sides like in massachusetts i
because i'm i
i call my mom if i go back to
massachusetts i have to get a hotel room
for two weeks right although and if i
don't they charge me 500 bucks a day but
what if the hotel
[ __ ] maid has it and she just well
yeah they don't come in they don't come
into the world
no housekeeping there's no room service
there's room service in
some states that's what's weird and
there's no
more coffee stands i know lobbies
you're right and that destroys me except
some the last place i was i was in uh
nashville they had it behind the counter
it's like you could ask the desk clerk
for a coffee
but you can't get it's just it's just
weird like you know what's funny
every airport has different standards
but you know the one thing that's
universal
you can use a water fountain at every
airport
which to me seems like the dirtiest
thing i don't even use what do you use
water fountains at the airport that's so
gross
you bring your own water yeah but
there's people in line to use the water
fountain still
so it's like i mean it's transferred
through liquid
i don't know all i know is you can't
catch it from
sex now let me ask you this i know you
have a boyfriend now i was i was
genuinely wondering this if you want to
know if you went on an app
would you like to be like listen we're
[ __ ] but we're not kissing like that
i don't know if i'd kiss somebody right
now i would [ __ ] them but i don't think
i'd kiss them well before the boyfriend
i dated a little
when this first because we got shut down
what march
13th or 12th or something like me and
him weren't together together
for a little while i'd kiss him if we
were dating but like if i met someone at
a bar
i wouldn't kiss him that night i don't
think well i wouldn't meet anyone at a
bar because there's no bar
but although there's restaurants i guess
you're right
i went out with a guy i did a lot of
covet dating
which is like someone sends you food
and you facetime while you eat it oh
yeah
it was awesome
it was awesome one guy sent me boa a
steak
your face is hilarious see this is what
would have happened to me if i
tried to date just buying a girl a steak
you know i'm getting it thank you i mean
kate i knew you were down everybody was
down i know scared
fears were up tensions were up i was so
depressed joey and we all
found different ways to cope with them
you know i have a wife
i got a family i thought about all the
single people
i was miserable at nine o'clock at night
my mind would go
into hell and i would
think about dean and lee and steve
simone
and you and [ __ ] you know people who
lived by themselves
all day it was rough because yeah in the
daytime you could take a ride to the
post office
you could stop by the corner and yell at
somebody
that's what i do you know seven o'clock
is when the comic comes to life
that's what it is once you do comedy for
five or six
years at six o'clock if you're a comic
wake up while you're eating dinner
something happens to you
people start talking to you and you
don't hear their words
because you're thinking about your 8 30
spot yeah and your 10 30 spot then you
find your quiet place
and like like nothing bothers me more
when i go into the bedroom before a set
like i tell my wife we got to go to the
comedy store and she's like oh okay
and i go into i lay out my clothes i put
my socks on
out yeah i lay my underwear on my shirt
once i jump in that shower that whole
process is getting me ready
yeah okay once i go in the shower
dawg if you come in there with a piece
of [ __ ] i wouldn't get a heart on
because i am thinking i know what you
want about comedy
and how i'm gonna do tonight and i'm
gonna try this joke first at the end
you're excited
yeah that's such excitement this time my
wife would come in and go
before you leave don't forget and i'm
like what like i don't even hear you
yeah because i am so deep in my thoughts
like you ever come out of the shower and
forget to brush your teeth because you
were so deep in your thoughts
not exactly you forgot to scrub your
ears yeah i forgot the point or wash
your hair twice
or three times yeah like i do that all
the time like god damn it
i didn't loosen my [ __ ] you know i
gotta go back in there now because i was
thinking about another sponge
i'm thinking about what i'm doing yeah
thinking about the drive to the store
the improv the the theater in chicago
you know once six o'clock comes when
you're a comic i don't understand if
people know what happens to you
but it's like if you guys they just talk
to your job they don't know like it's
like
having a job no we're not special
anybody else i know
if you're not if you're a plumber and in
the morning you're like i have a new
construction job today i'm [ __ ]
excited to quit your job if you're an
electrician and you're like man
i'm gonna do some saddles today at work
something different
you quit your job if you wake up in the
morning you're like man
i can't wait to put that partition up
and put that
you mean if you don't feel that way you
don't feel that way yeah i agree but i
think there's a difference between being
excited and like not saying you're
nervous but
like it's like to me it's like going to
a big meeting like that's what it would
be similar you're preparing
mentally yeah it's like going through
the motions it's kind of like uh
but i do it for everything yeah you do
it for everything yeah okay when you go
to the atm t stop for me it's sprint
when i go to the sprint store i look at
those people and i go
first off i give them always give them
10 stars
because they put up with [ __ ] you've
never even heard them
okay i've sat there a thousand times not
now now my phone looks like i got run
over by a truck
because i'm on the covered [ __ ] plan
you don't want to go in there
it's true because you know there's
covered in there like a [ __ ]
wearing a hat tonight seven
inches of roots i'm like when can i get
this done
so you know you you want to go in there
and do the phone you ever go into that
place and somebody really really takes
care
yeah like you're like i don't have my
pen and she's like hold on
boom boom and all of a sudden she starts
hitting numbers and she's like what
phone do you want this
well since she goes this what i'm gonna
do is save you 14 on this
just get this package and you feel like
amazed amazed like somebody's doing
their [ __ ] job
that person goes to work every day to
help people
now no disrespect to nobody that [ __ ]
that came on tv and i'm crying the nurse
he said i didn't sign up for this listen
i'm sorry
you took a nose yeah you did when i when
i sit here with you and i go i think i'm
gonna become a nurse
and then i get down and somebody goes
all right your first job is to clean
[ __ ]
you never even thought about that as a
nurse no but if you want to get the
section a you got to go to mr
mcgillicuddy who's built like me
pull them to the side you smell my farts
pick up my leg put a bucket under there
talk to me while i [ __ ]
and then wipe my [ __ ] ass takes a
certain type of individual
oh yeah i care we have a gay friend eric
he was working at a
old folks home during this there was
night i talked to him
that he was just getting home at
midnight and he was supposed to get off
at seven
oh yeah and he wasn't flying around
sucking dicks he told me in his heart
he was putting he was making sure those
patients
were taken care of correctly
yeah you know the guy from boston this
week some doctor of
uh covert died a 40-something year old
they're putting their life on the line
my step sister she works at a nursing
home or senior care facility and like
she works her day and then at the end
she hangs out with the coven patients
that are like critical
because they have no one they're alone
so you can put on a hazmat suit and hang
out with them
yeah they look like they have the new
facetime man covered facetime
is that true yeah like you just if you
got covered you're [ __ ]
shut up you're like serious with all
your kids
uncle joe am i gonna get the piano
am i going to get the piano he's on the
ventilator
oh my god i haven't [ __ ] even paid
for it yet you're taking me the [ __ ]
piano
oh it is crazy the whole thing is
[ __ ] weird i can't even talk about it
because it's become like
it's become the new like democrat
republican
like you can't talk about it right okay
listen we gotta remove
the politics from it for starters we
should because this is a human being
thing
so i for my world as soon as people
start talking about politics you lose me
yeah because people are dying there's no
politics involved here
this is [ __ ] this is people i don't
know what's going
on politics of people trying to save
people
yeah and making a situation better it's
so frustrating
right now politics is at a level that
it's scum
it's scum what's going on right now so
aside from that let's not get caught up
in that
let's get caught up in what's in front
of us which is people are dying
people are getting exposed some people
want to
wear a mask some people don't want to
wear a mask
and you worry about yourself
all you could do is yourself people are
furious at me
saying that black and white have
attacked me again after i said it
you know i hate no i don't hate it it
was a punch line for me for years
anybody who heard me say it say knows
that i do it for a laugh
but anybody who knows my voice and
listens to me and knows my soul
knows that i have black influences
i've been very very black influencers
there's people who have said to me man i
listened to the podcast
and until i saw your picture i thought
you were black and people are mad at me
because
i say that we shouldn't use the word no
more
that or black or white the underworld
yeah yeah because if a black person says
it
it gives a power to a white person if
you know
right now you have a dated guy yeah
every time you you've been wanting for
two years
he's a sweetheart yeah he's got a good
dick
i've never had that good family for two
years he's got a job
yeah yeah but every day every day
it's a doing every day
a flat he left his phone at the house
he ran over his phone yeah i agree
i agree you know and you you tolerated
for a while
until one day i don't know what the
point is of this story what the [ __ ]
no i know what you're saying you're like
the n-word is like that
so if it causes so much problem get rid
of it
if it causes so much [ __ ] problem
if you say that causes problem if you
say it i feel uneasy
if she said then just i'm not saying ban
the word
i'm saying why is that saying and i was
saying it to myself
what i could do what can you do right
now to help the situation
you can help your friends as much as you
can there's people that aren't eating
there's people that are struggling
yeah if you don't have money and you
know somebody's having a bad day call
them
yes check up on them check it
dirty [ __ ] absurd joke make them
giggle
go what are you doing right now watching
tv
put your mask on meet me in front of
your house in five minutes i got two
joints
yeah you know i can't tell you how much
it makes people's day
that's it that's it i went totally we
went down it was his birthday last
monday i didn't want to leave him alone
so i took up the ride
was with me happy with him and i i i
felt terrible i should have got his dick
sucked
i should have got him a [ __ ] something
you know what i'm saying
he's scared on my list he's afraid no i
mean i trust me i i want you to take a
blow job
yes i'm not offering it the issue with
the issue with the people he was saying
is one person
doesn't live in the state anymore and
the other person is someone who
doesn't matter you ever hook up with a
crazy person i just don't yeah have i
ever hooked up with a crazy i am look at
her
are you kidding me look at it when you
look up crazy it's uh
antenna her boyfriend smiling all right
look
it's her until her boyfriend's like yeah
pretty well it's at the point where i
like i told him i said
i'd rather not get a [ __ ] than call
that person that's insane
i know yeah it's not good well i've had
guys turn me down for being crazy
but i'm not crazy anymore i'm healed
look back
wait but actually i want to say
something about what you're saying
because
uh because my best friend growing up was
black
my boyfriend now is black and like
i have nev my best friend growing up she
was miss ohio
she's gorgeous black girl she's married
to a white guy
they have a son the son is super
light-skinned he's almost like border
albino like he's so light
they had to teach him not to say the
n-word because he looks white his blonde
hair
if he says it in the wrong crowd he
could get his ass kicked but also
i have never heard her say it my whole
life and i've known her since i was 12.
like she doesn't like the word for the
reason you're saying
and my boyfriend he doesn't really say
it either unless he's like rapping
to a song on the radio or something but
like he doesn't say it
at all and not there's i mean obviously
like
if you're black it's up to you obviously
like my friend jackson says it like some
guys say it but
i do agree that it can create like once
i felt entrapped
into saying it i was dating a black guy
actually it's hilarious i was dating a
black guy i never heard him say it
we were dating for like i don't know
three or four months he never said it
once
then when we were breaking up uh he said
you're the one
who told n words who blah blah blah and
i was like
i don't know any n words i texted it
and i texted it in quotes and i wrote a
z because you know you can't say er and
that's not what he said but my point was
i was trying to say i don't know any
because i don't use that word like i
hate that word
but he was like i can't believe you
wrote that i can't believe you like he
was so mad i was like i was entrapped
like i've never said it but like you
inter
and it was like a huge fight so
i just think i mean white people should
never
say it but yeah what's the reason
it it does give the word power it drives
me crazy i'm gonna look i love biggie i
love the 10 crack commandments
and all that stuff i listen to that
stuff and he's dropping it and i'm like
i'm singing along yeah i guess you can't
do that i've been told you can't do that
i heard warning is one of my favorite
songs i'm singing along and i'm catching
myself saying it but
it's not in that context so you know i'm
all [ __ ] up over it people got pissed
at me
anybody who knows me knows where my
heart is so
[ __ ] it you know what i still got an
afro pick
if i move to a [ __ ] if i move to a
humidity area wait till you see my hair
this gel disintegrates in humidity i
like that
my jew comes back my black jew please
tell me you have an afro pick
please grow your jew back i've always
saved an afro picket for real
yeah it was such a part of my life
i saved it i saved my safety can you
stick it in and leave it there you got
to grow up
when i was a kid oh my god and i would
go to harlem i would stick it in there
i'll put it in my back pocket
why not you put it in your back pocket
you can still see the black hand
coming out i guess there's a hand on it
yeah
black power i never saw the hand on one
i don't think it's the whole movie it's
a
it's a afro pick yeah with black power i
never saw that
oh that's cool so i grew up in the
harlem 68 69
and that was the idea i'm black and i'm
proud black power
so for you to go into harlem you got to
be a white dude with an afro pick
hilarious black power all the the black
colors the
the black green and uh what were the
black colors
the green yellow i didn't know that yeah
yeah back then
yeah african flag or something oh yeah
yeah
oh yeah black green and yellow or red or
something something so when i was a kid
it was completely different
yeah when you went to harlem but when
you went to harlem you also
it was like going to a museum it was
back in the day
it was different you really got to see
that was my thing on it like i went to
harlem and was treated like a gentleman
i know kids who went to harlem and got
beat up really but it was your body
language
how you walked in harlem if you walked
into harlem by the time you get to
fifth sixth avenue down there if you got
attitude by like four thousand you're
gonna get lit up
and then you stumble into [ __ ]
spanish home
and then you stumble into italian part
of harlem because all those harlems
that's where fat tony salerno's gangsta
[ __ ] thing was he was like 123.
i'm not you know what whatever social
club italian guy
yeah he's a gangster but around the
corner were all the black
numbers yeah and puerto rican and cuban
it's like prison policy banks
no it's not like prison so at the end of
the day
everybody had to pay fat tony to do
work in that area so but beside that i
mean
i had a history lesson like
i could tell you thousands of stories
that i learned
and where i learned my
appreciation for african americans yeah
was
walking on that street and this was
different then
tensions weren't high because everybody
knew where they stood
you know what kate three years ago you
didn't like me
and three years ago i didn't like you
let's keep it that way
we're not gonna walk we're not gonna say
hello goodbye to each other yeah
but we're just gonna keep it that way
and that's what it felt like
we kept ourselves you keep to yourself
and everybody gets their feelings sorry
you're right it's changed
it's changed now there's more tension a
lot of tension and you know people say
to me well joey
you should go on the road i'd love to go
on the road and i would wear a mask and
i would drive and i would do a thousand
things
it's not that that i'm scared of i'm
scared of the tension in the air
yeah i'm scared of lee going up and
somebody going shut up you [ __ ] jew
you know because that's what's going on
you see what felipe posted today
it was at the heart rock hotel casino
there was like eight people fighting
where just in the casino where vegas
yeah i i honestly think people are
because of the money thing and i
honestly think a lot of people aren't
getting feeling a lot of love right now
no i i've been a lot of stress in the
air
i've lived in my neighborhood for four
years my neighborhood is so diverse
have you been to my house i can't
remember no it's like literally my
building's mostly asian the next one's
african i mean african african not just
black the next one's middle eastern the
liquor stores black dudes it's really
diverse
not a lot of white people you go a few
blocks up there's white people
but like i never had any issues because
i
you know me i smile at everyone i say hi
to everybody i say i don't be like a
homeless guy peeing i'm like what's up
bro like i don't care but like
now i've had some people start to be
mean to me
for no reason and they're never white
people so it makes me feel like there's
more racial tension like i've had people
like get the [ __ ] out of our
neighborhood and it's
it's making me move asians are telling
you black guys not
no i've never had an agent no my
building's asian but there's a lot of
like
black guys mexican guys middle eastern
guys
like i had some black like high school
age kids
follow me one night like follow me two
blocks be like what's up [ __ ] get out
of our [ __ ] neighbor
like and i'm not saying obviously like
not all black but it's definitely never
happened before this
so i feel like white people like the
people who are
racist now are more vocally racist and
the people who are
pissed about that are more vocal too and
there's a lot of people in the middle
like who aren't racist like us but like
you're like well
but i look like this so you're the enemy
to some people
you know it's a weird time man like i
posted
okay during quarantine right when uh
all the riots started the protests right
you know everybody was posting about the
protests and i did for a couple weeks
and then i was like okay it's time to
somebody asked all that was being posted
was protest stuff
and i was like i just want there to be a
break in it
so i posted one day a selfie but i was
outside my apartment building and there
was a construction guy who always comes
out when i take selfies like the
building manager the maintenance guy he
always comes out
anytime he sees me taking a selfie like
comes and stands around watches
so i posted it and i just put a funny
caption
and it everybody was like thanks for
posting something different
but one black girl got really mad at me
she was like this is insensitive we're
mourning
the loss of our people to police
brutality and i was like i get it but
there has to be something else social
has media taken a work a turn for the
worse
oh totally over we used to reconnect
with friends
and to be a platform for us to giggle
and just say things for one another out
you
are looking at a different world i agree
people are not appreciative no more
um people get mad if you're funny i was
posting
the movie of the day for a while oh yeah
i liked that
i was getting tortured really yeah this
movie sucks
no not like that okay you know you got
to do this and you have to do this movie
what about
the sound of me and i just you know it
was out of me it was just
everything you did that you thought was
to help people
was you would get 50 complaints and then
i tweeted one thing and i got tortured
i tweeted something else that was just
about the you know i'm i'm here with a
gun waiting for the losers to kick in
you're an old paranoid [ __ ] it's people
like you that are ruining this country
oh
for protecting my seven-year-old with a
gun when there's a riot going on at the
sherman oaks galleria
you know yeah it's it's it's it's just
so
i i started a patreon i saw that a
dollar
what is it what do you put on it you
know what i put on it
man i give you a warning wake-up video
hello they say [ __ ]
you sign it up you know they have little
things that you could do like options
like your voice
yeah and you could just do a 10 minute
podcast if you want yep
on the day you know whatever you want
yeah you could uh
i i take songs and i tell them what they
mean to me
how i connected with those songs the
lyrics
i put pictures of my friends up oh [ __ ]
i wanted to give them
i wanted to give them something
different than a podcast i wanted to
give them
what i think behind the scenes that's
personal yeah and then as i
learn more options i'll do more you know
yeah
like i got okay every week i tell you
the blunder of the week
the what the blender
me too so i get this weed
it is stronger than that i only smoke in
the morning
[ __ ] whitaker's on i miss gustafsson
i watch abe lincoln against george
washington
you know nobody gary what's he talking
about noguera against shogun
and then i watch whitaker and whatever
all right and i went inside i did a
bongo to this weed this guy dropped it
off he called me and he goes i gotta
give you some of this that i grew
oh [ __ ] like [ __ ] it's like and he
only gave me like two joints three
joints
he goes this is all i got for you now
but before you leave i'm gonna give you
a pound of this
he goes this is gonna be the strongest
strain i've ever put together
and it's right your name but it's just
it's an indica
so i put it in front of the heater
during the fight i went out there
and i rolled a joint
i took the camera from [ __ ] i went on
patreon
got the camera you know pushed the
button that makes the flip
okay and i started doing my thing what's
up [ __ ]
sitting here boarding the saturday yeah
when the joints down to a roach i
realized i didn't turn the video on
this is the [ __ ] i do okay so now i
gotta roll another joint because i can't
let them down
um sorry oh god
i am [ __ ] gone i got three edibles in
me
i am [ __ ] gone and now i gotta burn
this other joint
not really i gotta do it
you commit and i did that the video
[ __ ]
worked this time but it wouldn't down
upload
patreon that's the thing you gotta do it
on your computer
it's hard from your phone no no i did on
the computer oh i didn't have my ipad
oh i didn't have my ipad so yeah i
smoked a whole joint
i did the best video i ever did to find
out
it wasn't even turned on well i did that
with my last podcast that's how stupid
i am i don't know if you know that
notice but
almost like every six minutes especially
when i'm high i do this
i'm only turning around just to make
sure it's recording because is it
yeah it's recording i've only done that
once and luckily it wasn't on this
podcast
but it's like that happens but
especially when you're high
but you know what i think it is dude
have you gotten a lot of hate on your
patreon
no i've noticed a lot of the hate i've
gotten recently i go to their page and
they're not even following me
oh yeah of course so i i think what it
is is if
if you can build your own thing the
people who actually like you aren't the
ones hating you
like there's people who just go around
and hate and they're not they're
probably following up a dollar to hate
me
oh yeah then please do that's what i
said that's why i did a dollar you
should do another level patreon where
it's like 10 bucks a month and
it's only for haters i would charge 20.
that's
hilarious to hate i hate and you post
the hate videos
that's a great idea video all your race
is stuck towards spanish people
bring it on get it out i know you're
living in an apartment without money
cockroaches
you know i would love that let's do a
hatreon
yeah i would have people [ __ ] said
hey you know just let it out if that's
what it means for you to be a better
person
yeah man let it out you know what this
sounds cheesy to say but that's the
reason
i think i connect with the guy that i'm
seeing
because i feel like i connect with
anybody in this business who gets kind
of like made fun of or
like [ __ ] on a little extra i connect
with them
i really do like everybody i love in the
business
has a struggle or has that was weird
there's a ghost in here
has a struggle or has like just tended
on the side whatever it's fine
has something going on joey
i don't have covert i'm positive but uh
yeah because i feel like that it's like
if you're different at all you think
outside the box
people hate but they help you because
like really real talk they boost your
algorithm with their comments
like every mean comment is one more
person who sees your post
because it boosts your post so in the
end they're
helping you make money it's uh it's
really crazy
and that you know what i used to feed
into it now
i have i have i have to have
20 on my facebook to definitely have
mental health
oh for sure
i get some emails on facebook that are
very scary and then they come back and
go sorry about all that
i went off my medication me too are you
serious
i had a stalker do that at a stalker
sorry about that i was on a bender
holy [ __ ] sorry about that i was really
drunk when i wrote this last night
i get that all the time i won't answer
them back because i know there's a
reason
nobody just i there's no reason for me
to open up an email
on facebook messenger or facebook and
have pure hate i don't even answer it
i'll give them a thumbs up
then two days later they'll roll back go
ahead
i went off my medication i don't really
feel that way
i just wanted to attack you because
you didn't play you shook me all night
long
or some [ __ ] you know it's really weird
or the other way
i'll get like three kate you're the best
kate you're so funny
kate i love you on the church go suck a
[ __ ] dick you hurt like the next one
is so mean i know i saw something with
you on facebook
about two months ago where somebody went
after you and i had and i went to his
public message
and i go hey man get it together
i love you if you don't like something
you know i'm from the school you don't
like it turn it off
i don't like saying that live i've never
had liked it
that doesn't mean i'm going to get on
their yelp page and write about right
me neither i'm not going to make
somebody feel bad
if i don't like that product unless they
ask me to try to force it down my throat
no i don't want to be a scientologist
you know what i'm saying
no i don't want to do it no no i don't
give a [ __ ] if joe and i don't give a
[ __ ] about
martian meat i don't give a [ __ ] it yeah
that's a new thing
is that real yeah martian they just
captured them what do you think they did
with the meat
that meat that tastes funny there's no
more lizard meat
now it's marching look at lee look at me
going oh my god
what i think i had some yes you did i'm
sure
i i do love how no one's talking about
that by the way what's up
they admitted that they were aliens and
everyone just so freaked out pissed off
they're like
we'll get to this later like dude they
admitted that we have a
what and guess what nobody cares about
ufos now
we've known about it for 50 [ __ ]
years we've told you we've seen them
you denied them you've played games with
us
you know like i told florentine here one
time
the highest the highest place to see was
where it took you
that hotel in edgewater that we stayed
at in jersey
wait the weekend you went back
that's number one place to see uh
satellites in the country
is the new york skyline satellites or
ufos ufos
i wonder if they go to new york they fly
of course they do they fly people see
[ __ ] all through those buildings dude i
probably [ __ ] the alien new york you
don't know what they look like they
could have people's skin on
there's a lot of [ __ ] weirdos in new
york i feel like some of them were at
our table at that chinese church
oh my god what do you [ __ ] alien i
hope i [ __ ] the alien do you know how
offended i would be
if aliens were here and i haven't [ __ ]
one like none of them i haven't been
abducted yet what the [ __ ]
i'm a specimen i want to know if any guy
has taken you serious
about the boyfriend because i haven't
announced it until this really
when i was rocking and rolling like if i
came up to you and said kid i got an
eight ball you're coming back to the
hotel
and you'd say yeah on the way there
you'd say hold on let me call my
boyfriend
and i tell you put the phone down forget
the boyfriend's done tonight
he's fired i just fouled the [ __ ]
motion
he's not gonna know nothing about you
till six in the morning you know
yeah like i know has anybody called you
and tried to hook up
of course and you said that lots of
people yeah i just it's the easiest
thing
i really did yeah in fact this is funny
this is actually how we became
a couple uh he won't care if i tell us
right at the beginning of this
like we were talking a lot we were
really like talking every night
and then there was one night he was out
i was out we both we hadn't talked in a
few hours which sounds crazy but like
we've been texting every like couple
hours right
we hadn't talked and a guy hit me up
who i've gone out with before but not
hooked up with
and i like had a crush on this guy
like i would have gone out with him
again so
he hit me up and said hey uh if you're
in the neighborhood i'm having a party
at my spot
i got a bunch of people coming over
we're getting somali it's gonna be a
good time you should come through
and i was like man
i'd love to but i knew this dude was
gonna facetime me or call me or
something
and i didn't want to lie so i just told
the other guy i was like i started
seeing this guy
and i really i think it's kind of
serious but it's not but like i
i feel weird about doing it he was like
oh you're in love and i was like i don't
know what it is but i just
i think we should like wait a week or
two and see what happens
and then i go home that night and he
facetimes me
and he tells me a story about how he
went to a dinner that night
and he was like a solo guy at a couple's
dinner and his friend had brought a girl
for him and he didn't know what was
going to happen
and she wanted to go home with them and
he was like
uh i'm kind of talking this girl i
really so that's how we ended up not
seeing other people was because we ended
up both turning down
sex like
it's like crazy for you tell your
grandkids one day yeah so it was like
just by accident but honestly i've
avoided situations where i'd be tempted
like there's been a night or two we've
had a fight maybe like you know
who you know who hits me up or somebody
hits me up
and i would normally go but i i've just
been not going
because i know i'm weak
so i stay home at least you're honest
man
how do you how has this love changed you
in hawaii what are you thinking
is it does it is it taken away from your
comedy a little bit
i worry about that but there's a lot of
jokes about him
but i can't say who but like there's a
lot of material there i just can't do it
it's so funny because i've been here a
long time yeah
and i see the evolution of women and
a girl again to comedy 23 24
best piece of ass you know at her best
time she's beautiful
she does comedy she gets a special
road the whole thing and then maybe
she'll date a comic for a year and that
doesn't work out
yeah and then one day you bump into and
she's like i
met a guy and it's like completely
different from her world maybe he's a
writer maybe he's an electrician
yeah on the set you know i wanted
and then i hate to say this and
this is the only it's not a knock i have
for women
yeah yeah not a knock whatsoever but
guess what
your ovaries come calling oh hell no i'm
not having kids
women's ovaries this guy's snipped
carbon quality
no i don't care i'll give you my sperm
you can put it in there with a syringe
you'll still have a bat i don't want to
get i still have an afro and you know
you just tell them whatever you need but
my point is it's so weird that
i've seen i and i can tell you by name
but it's nobody's business
yeah i've seen tons of women i have to
be great
for giving [ __ ] hard and then their
ovaries come calling love comes calling
and stand up is now number two and it
should be because
your child is number one i don't want a
kid but i will tell you
like i changed a little bit of how i was
behaving
just because he has a kid and i haven't
met the kid or anything
but like if his kid is following me on
social media i don't want to have my ass
out you know so i've been a little
different
but the cool thing is like this guy's
done what he wants already
with his career like he'll do more but
he's like
he wants me to succeed so like now i can
still do whatever i want
like this tour he hates it he doesn't
hate it but he doesn't want me really
staying at truck stops and camping and
like
i was going to invite my fans like for a
thousand dollars you can camp at my site
and he was like girls have the worst
ideas what the hell lee i need money
dude just i know he has money but i
won't take his money that's all right
that's one of my least favorite parts
about dating is when a girl is like yeah
i'm going to go camping
across the country and you care about
them and you don't want to like
and you're not really angry but you care
about them and they say something like
that
and you're just like and then you get
mad when he gets mad
i'm not mad but like i can camp you know
when does this camping thing [ __ ]
start august 1st
where does it go from okay so what we're
doing is going from here to nashville
but we're stopping
uh a bunch of locations like utah
estes park the rockies i might do i'm
trying to do a comedy work show like a
one night because
they open yeah they're open are they
open yeah but i mean
it's not downtown the other one the
other one
i don't know the south the west side's
outside i'm not sure
but then we're going to new mexico
oklahoma city
uh ozark memphis nashville and i'm gonna
do the hollywood pool party at truck
stops ta
is gonna like pay for all our gas and
give us like
food and showers so i'll do that there
and interview truck drivers and it'll be
a pay-per-view live stream
so for like five bucks you can watch for
a little more you can engage
you need to do a video from the truck
stop showers
those have to be disgusting no they're
amazing are they really
never showered in a truck stop no dude
they're so clean
no it's like a hotel yeah those guys
cabs
like i've slept in a in a 18 wheeler the
cab is like a hotel room
not quite as big but yeah wow they're
dope
i had no idea yeah i'm excited and then
we're going to camp at koas
so it's every other night truck stop koa
truck stop koa
i'm just worried about uh i'm worried
about you
you know there's a lot of uh like i said
there's no covert
it's more the un settling
of the air and yeah so i just want you
to promise us you'll be
careful i will bring the gun i don't
have a gun
can you put one of those things on your
[ __ ] like they did in the old days with
a lock
oh uh a chastity bag yeah i'll do i can
do that you buy it i'll do it no no
we'll look it up online well doug
chastity bell your [ __ ] we'll cover
that too
let's look it up and then see if we get
your chassis because
she's going to [ __ ] just in case 10
[ __ ] truckers rip your pants off on
the site
i don't think that's going to happen and
[ __ ] they go to [ __ ] a little
monkey
and then we'll put like a throat block
in here too
like a little call leave that in your
mouth so they can't put their dick all
the
way
down it's just over here like that's
hilarious
like a hockey mask that's covered for
real they can't get in
it's going to be covered with netting
for comics and truck drivers no [ __ ]
ears so you gotta put like
this cause they're blows right in those
truck drivers don't give a [ __ ] they do
matter
yeah they jump in the armpit they don't
give a [ __ ]
it's gonna be very safe and i'm gonna
have no long hair on the armpits because
it's like titty [ __ ] an arm
i have not had that no i'm bringing a
follow car
with two people to shoot and actually
like one person
the reason i'm doing it is because i'm
working with a company that sells uh
like basically event ticketing for
digital now that we're there but i don't
want to do stand-up that way
personally yeah are you going to take a
lead from the president all the
governors you're going to bring a deaf
person with you
to do the translation are they all busy
you know what i've never seen
i want [ __ ] deaf translators haven't
worked this long
since [ __ ] 1922. and they're the
worst i don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're saying dude i love
translators they're fun you don't speak
sign language at all
no i love it noises and faces with her
face
and that one of them is attractive not
one of those [ __ ]
not one of those [ __ ] i'm telling you
this is your next
one listen to me not one of those
[ __ ] people
are [ __ ] hand doing anybody even deaf
people like what the [ __ ] are they
saying
they're doing things like this like
[ __ ] land they're never deaf
it does seem unfair like you know i know
what about blind people
what about if you [ __ ] hear you all
right
but they can't see you how come it's
always got to be for [ __ ]
deaf people my phone has blind
translations what about a deaf person
with a dog
that's what i want to see you've seen
hand signals with a dog
where's the safety dog where's the
safety dog
she's deaf where's the dog i don't know
man i all i know is i i have not seen
any safety dogs flying
nothing pisses me off in these speeches
and then something yeah
garcetti gave a speech that he had like
plan b
like they had a switch like timeout and
another deaf guy came out like
from ringing the bell shut up church
he's out there [ __ ]
because garcetti will give you here
beating the lady
how great would it be to learn sign
language just enough to get hired for
one speech and then just do whatever the
[ __ ] you like do your whole
life how great would it be if you had a
comedy school and you got to like either
you became a comic or you became a
[ __ ]
deaf translator can i talk to you for a
second i've been watching some of your
comedy shows and
you really don't got it but i think you
got something for deaf people
if you don't talk you can really be
entertaining jumping why are you looking
directly at me
no no no light your eyebrows on fire you
know [ __ ] like that
that'll work no i'm not going to have
have you seen the videos of the
of the translators who don't know what
they're doing they don't none of them do
not they're already that's what i'm
saying learn enough to get hired and
then do whatever you want like
that's people at home going i don't know
what this [ __ ] covenant what's coping
making those you ever see the chubby
black chick with the big glasses
she's the worst who she's the worst the
chubby black chick with the glasses she
talks or signs
science the worst she's like the chick
from uh the white haired chick
you should wear a mask
oh no i don't watch any of the politics
[ __ ]
no it's not politics it's on a world
news tonight you're the only one who
watches the news joe i think you're
literally the only person left to
watch six is six thirty yeah what's
going on in my area
i want to know i want to know what's
going on nationwide even though i know
that [ __ ]
i don't know [ __ ] i know they're
bullshitting me i don't know what you
really have to do is go on three
channels
and make a hypothesis well guess what i
don't have that type of time so what i
assumed was people getting sick people
dying what can i do not hang out in big
crowds do i talk to dirty people
if i smoke cover and turn around if i
smell coconut yeah you can smell it
i went somewhere yesterday and i smelt
it with the mask
shut up that was your own fart you
smelled at trader joe's i'm not going to
say where i went yesterday
but i'll give you a hint that was in
burbank and i walked in with the mask
and they had all the doors shut and the
air had that warmth to it
with covered breeds they're walking
around with no [ __ ] mask on jesus
what where's this at
come on i'm not going to say that that's
pretty [ __ ] bad
i just know this i know that i know that
listen i was thinking of stopping this
podcast when covert hit
no yes because i i couldn't live with
myself
i quit it if somebody came in here and
got sick
it's not for me i don't have that type
of ten years ago i would have sprayed
covert in your eye i don't give a [ __ ]
i would have put it in your drink but
now i have a wife
it would have been the least of our
problems yeah oh i snorted
i'm saying like [ __ ] colbert cover
this dick i would have rubbed it on my
balls and pissed it in your face
i would have packed the pellet and my
dick when i come it would hit your
palate
and it blow up or cover it then the [ __ ]
would come over it
and really activate it like promo salsa
like out the celsius what i'm saying
like
so i'm really petrified of that
i would love to go out and do comedy but
guess what
even the social distancing comedy i'm
not into doing
i don't want to put that many people
together i have nothing that important
to [ __ ] say no
okay i really don't if i don't get two
weeks of proper training before
salt lake city wise guys you're not
going to be good anyway
no yeah that's really funny why would i
want to let people see me
in my worst situation yes i could be
entertaining
i could no it's harder but i'm not going
to be 25 worth entertaining
yeah and i'm not going to be 35 hours
worth of entertaining so why are we
going to do this
i'd rather take my time off move get my
life together
get my family situated let lego see his
family
let lee decide what he wants to do and
somewhere along that
where i'm going tommy open up and i'll
start right back
i'm so excited about restarting me too
go on i'm going to go buy the judy
carter book no wait i have it i'll give
it to you i'm going to go back out at my
house
from scratch and i'm going to just do
and
fall in love with it i get that like
three months
just to fall in love with it no gigs
just to no responsibility
yeah okay you're doing a room tonight
yeah swing by and do 10
i'll let you close it i'll give you a
hundred i don't even want it
yeah let me just come down and do the
ten just to build up again
build some good credibility with the
with karma
you know get that good comedy karma got
to help out some people in some rooms
yeah and then go back on the road but
where i think i'm gonna move um access
to 20 comedy clubs without taking a
[ __ ] plane
so i could drive to a lot of stuff so
i'm very excited about that i'm excited
i'm excited about the second you know
like you always
i'm going back to law school and i'm
gonna do it right this time yep
i already went for 29 years i've been
lingering at law school like
hanging on to people and talking to
people and asking questions
now i'm going to do comedy how i wanted
to do it oh yeah
i might switch from being dirty [ __ ] it
why not i might be able to
i have so many opportunities hot pockets
i'll talk about hot pockets and lighter
bacon and yeah
i give bacon to jews on purpose
i'm out there giving up making the jews
i don't give a [ __ ] jack
who else can we offend yeah you know i i
wonder if there's a different style
i wonder if i've been watching a lot of
lenny bruce lately
and i'm going back to like i like that
60s he calls everybody a cat see
this cat see and he was pretty cool you
see i like that like that rhythm he had
he had like a jazz
to his stand up nobody has that anymore
i love bloody verses we all have
netflix comedy now we all are netflix
comics now
we don't have that jazz to us yeah
relaxation
that i'm eliminating all that i'm taking
all that out of my life so
it's over now i'm gonna be better than
ever i'll tell you
those shows i did the weekends i did
like
it was the most fun i've had in so long
because you can't do your old [ __ ]
you can't go on stage be like oh tinder
it's not irrelevant it's like
you have to talk about now but you don't
have time to build all new materials so
like it was really fun to just go up
and like i got new bits just out of
what's happening right now being angry i
know i haven't
really known my opening bid is gonna be
yeah who's got toilet paper left
yeah what was the toilet paper for
people are dying
and you're buying toilet paper can
anybody give me the [ __ ] logic behind
that that's so [ __ ] dope toilet paper
was gone nobody said nothing about
toilet paper i didn't stock up
i was talking about baby wipes tampons
and
uh you should have seen the gun spots in
burbank
yeah oh i saw oh no i'm gonna [ __ ]
die
i drove by one day they go whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no dude it's
crazy easy
it's scary we have people are buying
guns and it's
a disease i could see if we were getting
attacked
yeah but in my neighborhood people were
like i heard
you tell me you saw a naked guy with a
fidget spinner
castro mask riding down hollywood
boulevard at like
one in the morning on a bicycle in the
middle of the road naked
that's when it's time to pack up your
bag get the [ __ ]
yeah something is not right yeah but you
know i feel like in a way that
like for me i mean you remember i told
you before this i was burnt out on the
dating [ __ ]
i was feeling a little just like i
wanted to change it up and then this
happened
and then now it's forced me to come up
with other things so now i've got like a
whole new plan for like
digital stuff but if if this hadn't
happened i would just keep doing the
same
[ __ ] and now it's like i feel like my
life's going the way it's supposed to be
like this element and i feel like a lot
of people you know we all sat around
depressed at the beginning i [ __ ]
drank and it's funny like you were
saying like you're tweeting all night
i probably didn't sleep for a week like
i was
i was alone all my friends who have
families didn't want to hang
i had like two people to see i have a
friend with hiv
who was not afraid because he thinks
whatever he's taking for that
is keeping people only only four percent
have been affected
than uh they haven't people with hiv
yeah
really it's been really low yeah i think
hiv
topples covered get out of here it does
it's yeah whatever they're taking
in fact it was funny at one point he was
like do you want to take my stuff i was
like
okay but yeah yeah
but i was like i was just really
depressed
but i was also then after about uh four
weeks of that i was like
okay maybe this is like whatever higher
power
or whatever is out there is like hey
you've been wanting to start fresh here
it is
and that's why i didn't do my podcast
for a while because i was like
i really was falling in love with this
guy and i was like i don't want to [ __ ]
it up
like every time i talk about a guy in my
podcast it ruins it
and i couldn't have guests and i think
zoom is weird so i was just like you
know just gonna take a break and not
feel guilty about it and get my [ __ ]
together
you know what man i think when i went
home last year to shoot the sopranos
when it started hitting me how
monotonous my life was out here yeah
what it was so
revolved around work and not going to a
restaurant my buddies anymore and just
going give me the [ __ ] menu
right when i went home i realized that
my friends go out every night
yeah at 9 30 they're looking at their
clocks
they're like oh it's getting late and
that's fine
yeah but for two hours we sat there we
ate
we talked and i did that every night i
would go over the oh boy take the ferry
over
and i'm like you know what i think this
is what i miss
me too you know i was doing two podcasts
a week
or three shows at the store or two
podcasts a week
and a weekend at a club or two two
places and two different nights now
i didn't get into comedy to sit at home
yeah but it felt like tommy had just
i was disenchanted with comedy since i
shot the netflix special
yeah i felt that when i came back from
vegas i was disenchanted
yeah completely if it was up to me i
would have fired everybody and started
from scratch
yeah i took a little sabbatical i
dedicated myself to the store
yep god douche it was fire though
your stuff that you were doing after
that was so no no
i i didn't give a [ __ ] no more i know it
was amazing you really couldn't do
nothing to me i didn't really want to be
on netflix
i didn't want to be on hbo i didn't want
to be on camera you're having fun
i'm having fun you know what i'll get
somebody i'll pay somebody 50 bucks
[ __ ] tape me for 10 minutes put it on
youtube it's just as good as the hbo's
face just it's good it is just as good
as the hbo special
more
it's like uh i just
i've accepted what's com and that's what
a lot of people have to do and i said
the other day
i spoke to three people i'm not gonna
say what their names are they're
powerful people yeah
yeah one guy facetimed me because
something's going on with his phone
and he wouldn't make eye contact with me
on the facetime
well i kept rubbing his head and telling
me what's going on and then i go oh
sit down and look at me for a second
he goes what's up i go first off you're
telling me about everything that's going
on
wrong with your life let me take a
minute and tell you all the good things
you did with your life
yeah you did this you did this you did
this
you did this and you did this when i go
to this comedy club i see your name on
the wall
so before you take yourself into this
deep hole that's not worth it
because we're blaming each other we're
blaming ourselves for someone
this wouldn't happen this wouldn't have
happened if i work for my father bet you
you just gave me
chills you didn't want to be an editor
sorry
this what was better i would have a job
now i would be an all no you wouldn't
you'd be editing from the [ __ ] house
you know like
people really don't know what they have
so before you start
following god that's true what do they
call that wallowing
wallowing wallowing
about your [ __ ] 1200 check about your
[ __ ] 300
unemployment that they're going to cut i
want you to take that time
and i want you to this is a time to
re-evaluate
yeah look at the things you have done
you went to college on your own nickel
you paid your loans on your own nickel
you know what man so unemployment's
giving you
1800 and your rent is 1600
and your car payment streets all right
we got a problem here
but it's not a big problem yeah guess
what you know what
what are you gonna do watch narcos on
netflix
swipe it that's 80 a year right there
that water you're drinking from the
thing so [ __ ] get [ __ ] fountain
water
you drink water growing up dude you
[ __ ] morons listen
drink some water you know what cut out
coupons like grandma does
yeah cut it out you know what i started
wearing 99 cent store
makeup that's like cut out yeah man i
still look good
i got a [ __ ] awesome you cannot live
the regular life you were living you're
going to sacrifice
some stuff you're going to sacrifice
some stuff
and that's fine you're going to realize
you're going to look at me one day and
go joey
i got rid of netflix well something
that surprised me when i moved out here
is i thought it was just up you know i
thought like
you should like you started out low but
then you just keep making more money and
more money oh hell no
yeah like and just because you go down
for a little bit you're going to go
like it's going to go back up again like
i i i was an idiot i don't know i just
thought you would just keep going up
and that's how it was but sometimes you
don't have a job for a little bit
and la like california gets a lot of
hate
i don't i'm not leaving california
because i hate i'm not leaving
i love california la la it feels like a
business trip to me
you like you said like you don't have i
have friends that i met at work
but they live 15 miles away and
in a normal city that would be fine but
here that's an hour and a half each way
and you just don't see each other
yeah and yeah and people here it's just
this is you you come here to to do
business and i think what i realized
is i did i had a good run i got done
no i'm not i'm not done but i i worked
on a few cool tv shows
i worked i did this listen listen you
have to tell yourself
like you did more than 99
of the people who come here the minute
you get paid the first time for stepping
on the stage
that's what i tell myself when i get
down when i'm like i don't have the
netflix special i don't have an hbo
but like okay but i've got paid to play
clubs theaters had a tv show you
win when you get paid the first time i
won
the thing i'll never forget and and i
owe it all i owe a lot to joey
but that me doing the wilbur and
i could go home and work it it was weird
when i was going
to college i went to buy a laptop and
the guy at the apple store
was like oh i did video editing in l.a
for a little bit i worked in a couple
shows
and now i'm back here yeah he's working
at the apple store
and when i was 18 i was like that's
never going to happen to me he's a loser
he's working on the apple store
and now i'm like you have different
parts of your life like yeah maybe he's
happier than the apples
also that's the thing like maybe he is
happy
like i've had i really believe like
there's been moments
that i know i could have taken something
that would make me like
bigger but i didn't want it like
sometimes it's okay like
i don't know i love doing comedy i like
making people happy
do i want to be famous not
really like famous is hard as [ __ ] it's
very hard
and people assume you're rich when
you're famous people assume you know i
applied for food stamps when this
started
because like i never got unemployment i
applied twice
the first time i applied wrong second
time i applied right and then ever since
then it's been like
trying to merge the two accounts it
doesn't matter
i applied for food stamps i couldn't get
them like i was qualified
but i couldn't get both times at an
appointment no one called me
then i called they said they have to
call you back and it was like
if like realistically
it's just when you're in this business
it's like what you said
people think you get a tv show you make
it and
it's not it's like but but
i've also learned that none of that
matters but what is making
that's it money isn't making it i think
making it
making it money is making what do you
think it is
i think it's peace you know what it's
peace
and it's making it is
i'm never gonna be dave chappelle i'm
never gonna be kevin hart
i'm never gonna be bill burr do you care
but if
i cut out just a little part i could
have my own little piece of the pie
i could care who takes the rest i just
always wanted my own little piece of the
pie
if you think 15 years ago i'd tell you
today stand up i'd be in this position i
love you joey
i would be lying to you i don't want to
be dave chappelle i never claimed to be
charbelle or bill burr
or rogan or kevin hart but you are
russell peterson funny as all that
doesn't really matter funny doesn't
matter it's how you come across
that audience there's people that are
horrible
there's people that are horrible and go
from tv show to tv show
they've been on more shows and have gone
down than ever those are the guys that
get the more work
you know so it's like uh i've had to
make
peace for people the last three months
people have called me and said hey i'm
thinking of leaving
what do you think and i've said you know
you better get get the hell out of here
you told me that i was sad when you told
me when you called me and said
you should move gus go live in nashville
yeah i was like oh man joey thinks i
should give up
no i know you didn't i know you didn't
get what not give up
you better i don't want what's going on
listen
[ __ ] rose downhill and what's happening
in seattle and portland
we have those same type of people down
here
it's scary that are ready to go so you
have to give this
six weeks before hollywood
or downtown is looking like seattle i
got to leave home
they're going to take over the federal
building in l.a something
starts to happen in l.a remember when la
catches a cold and sneezes when la
sneezes
uphill everybody catches the cold [ __ ]
runs downhill if shit's going on in
portland
believe it or not oregon borders los
angeles uh
california so guys this is going to move
downward
yeah and if it's starting in austin and
it connects in arizona
it's just a civil war we're talking
about it's what are we talking about
armed people walked down louisville the
other day all these things are happening
i'm not this is a comedy podcast i'm not
telling you these things to scare you
i'm telling you these things to be aware
to know
what your surroundings are which is the
most important thing in life
when you get out of your car from now on
i don't want to see you on your cell
phone
if you didn't think i wanted to have
your cell phone on the street before
now if i see you i pull over and beep at
you
because there's a thousand videos out
there people looking at their cell
phones and somebody coming up and
punching in the [ __ ] head
yeah well you've known me a long time
i've never been scared
and i'm leaving my neighborhood before
you park your car yeah
i want you to take a ride and see if
there's anybody behind the tree or
anything
yeah there's mental health people going
on out there you know
these people who getting into arguments
with people put on a mask
you see somebody without a mask across
the street don't you
you don't know where they came from what
if they haven't gotten their dick sucked
their wife left them for the mexican
landlord and
they got the house got foreclosed for
that's true they go for a walk to get
anxiety uh anxiety here and you go put
on a mask
let's say that guy has a [ __ ] box
cutter
you know he's just his wife left him for
the guy who mows the lawn
yeah his house is foreclosed his
business is gone
and you're going to tell him to put on a
mask he's worried about the mask yeah
that guy's hoping he gets hit by the
covered train
and yeah he hopes that young kim sends
him a [ __ ]
covert missile right to his [ __ ] head
you know what i'm saying
no it's true like not to be like debbie
downer like yeah this is supposed to be
funny but like
the statistics for suicide are up
statistics for
people being uh 5150 are up so like you
have to check on your friends like
people
this is you know in prison it's a
punishment to be
in solitary confinement that's basically
what we're telling people to do is like
if you're
you you haven't been hugged you said
since what march yeah no
it's not but also i mean and joey used
to give me [ __ ] for it
i was pretty much like this i'm not good
at making
friends like comedy was good for me to
make friends
but it's a lot of time a lot of time in
l.a it's
by yourself that's true but you know
what before this that's true but every
time i saw you
i gave you a hug oh yeah and like people
need to people need to be touched
like like babies who aren't touched it's
like
there are statistics you can read about
babies who aren't touched who become
criminals because like
the psychosis of being touched is
important you need to feel loved
so you're saying the me too thing is
over
[Laughter]
i think it is over man i think
everything's over rose mcgowan said
something good
she's [ __ ] out okay quickly wicked i
love these dates
i'm so happy you found love yeah
knew for a long time that that was a gap
in your heart
everybody you met was a piece of [ __ ]
yeah
and you're fine you know and again you
got to suck a thousand dicks
before dude it's so funny i came in here
joey said you gotta you gotta suck a
thousand
dicks to find a prince and i was like i
tweeted that last week but this is why
we have like uh you're just you're my
spirit animal how many
[ __ ] did i eat before i ate the right
person you tell me
20 thousand 20 that's why if you swab my
mouth
with the if you do the [ __ ]
testing just pregnant it's just going to
come up [ __ ] like listen
you don't have covert you have like an
[ __ ] growing in you who's the guy who
said he got throat cancer from eating
[ __ ] michael
douglas yeah and i feel different i
think it's good for his felt grandson
no it is [ __ ] you got to hear me sing
the next day
it's not unusual to make love to anyone
that's awesome no it's real where can
they find you okay quick you guys can
find me on social media you know where
these toys are
funny but but uh the website is
ticksar.com
t-i-x-r so the whole tour will be on
there
if you want to watch it it'll be on
there it'll also be on my youtube
channel she's also gonna put a camera in
her tent and that's a special ten
dollars
shut up joe put a little bras on
he's right play with him i bought a
water bottle that you can
pee into and filter it and drink it oh
the worst case scenario that's a hundred
dollars
holiday and experience and listen to me
if you drink it
if you drink cupcakes breakfast if you
drink cup piss from the camping trip
i'll give you two cash
and enter you in the contest along with
lee to who takes the fart in the face
with lee solina doesn't have to do it
alone
that's how we're gonna end the podcast i
got the chick i'm she's eating as we
speak
i went over and bought like four miles
with the groceries
marshmallows who what are you talking
about i have a uh
african-american woman who weighs about
480. what
she's going to come here on camera and
fought in leisure now
not tonight oh i'm like i'm staying
this has been going on for seven years i
put a bibb on his shirt
the whole thing would have put a bit
behind him he calls me a real other day
with like a new idea i give her
anti-diarrhea manga
she has a little bit a diarrhea just
don't do that let her let her diary
right now
i'm making him a millionaire i'm his
manager
this guy [ __ ] couldn't manage himself
yeah but you always say i'm gonna be a
millionaire and then you say the first
one's for free
you have to eat for free you can't leave
town without having
one ass can we please set it up i will i
will pay for it
it's my food sale i'm not i'm not doing
a hooker the first one
is just a fart to the face okay
and that's it that ends you get some
latch you get a half a million
you get a million views you get some
t-shirts made 1 million
i survived the flight to the face you
know that's the name of the website i've
survived the fight for the face watch
him get he's going to he's going to get
he's not writing this down because he's
a [ __ ] i'm not
and then we're gonna do a pay-per-view
event we're like yeah yeah
people get [ __ ] up by chubby chicks
and [ __ ] like
you're gonna chubby check the zip line
and you're gonna eat
your mouth like this and she just lands
with a [ __ ] in your mouth and if you
catch a pubic hair you win a hundred
dollars whatever how about this i
started only fans and it's 200 a month
and all you do is eat ass sure yes
200 is too much no it's too much for it
because we're gonna we're not gonna get
you
each person is doing wiggly looking
[ __ ] i'm gonna get you
ayahuasca looking [ __ ] with broken
hips recovering from
[ __ ] allergies oh they just got shot
in the leg in vietnam one of those
just now just now yeah death row
women that's real you ever see like when
the [ __ ] drags
what do you mean drag you haven't seen
that yo
i'm gonna get you one of those what is
i'm going to give you like a selection
of asses i got it all planned out yeah
but none of them sound good
it sounds like [ __ ] it's going to be
great i'll throw a few hot wheels
[ __ ] content of vitamin c a lot of
people it's true
and ginger and ginger so you'll be
really ginger
anyway forget about lee getting fought
in the face
the church is brought to you by
draftkings
all right nba mlb if they don't have
[ __ ]
uh colvin mma golf
draftkings has it all plus paying props
like how many players are gonna die this
season
joey live betting and more listen
whether you like it or not
you're gambling your life away every
time you go down the corner for a
[ __ ] thing of milk
every time we talk to that young kid
jumping up and down
you might get covered so you might as
well [ __ ] go in deep if you're
walking on ice
you might as well dance draftkings is
the answer
i mean look at thursday tomorrow live
from disney world
i hope [ __ ] uh the guy from the
clippers didn't escape to go to a
[ __ ] strip club again
you got the clippers against the lakers
and you got the pelicans against the
jazz all right
to celebrate draftkings is going to give
you 25
you're sitting there going joey how how
you going to place a 25
bet on which team will be crowned the
champion at the end of the nba season
that's the team with the les covent
that's who's gonna [ __ ] win that
do it before tip off tomorrow because by
the end of the season they're gonna have
five guys on the most players
three on one two on the other one the
one that's got three got a broken elbow
that's why they let them play
clover don't let them heal at the end
and by november it's gonna be three guys
on the court watch
all right so what we're gonna do is this
whether you want baseball
basketball mma or golf draftkings has it
all
they got the player pops they got the
live betting and they got more
if draftking sportsbook isn't available
where you live yet
don't forget about the draftkings
fantasy app
for this weekend's golf tournament
they're offering a share of ready for
this
yeah one million dollars shut up
one million dollars so listen i've been
around the block on this
and there's one thing i can tell you
there's a reason draftking
is america's number one sportsbook and
they really are
they're safe secure and they're reliable
if you want to get in on some action
this weekend or tomorrow
download draftking sportsbook now and
use code church c-h-u-r-c-h
plus for limited time for the church
[ __ ] family
all new users get a sign-up bonus of a
geno
leroux that's a grand when you get
draftkings sports app
and use code church only
that's a covert making a comeback only
at draftkingsportsbook
and here's the part the lawyers want me
to say you got to be 21 over
new jersey indiana and pennsylvania only
deposit bonus requires a 25-time play
through restrictions do apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling problem
there's help for you okay you call 1-800
gambler
and if you're in indiana you call 1-809
with it
and tell them uncle joey sent you if
you're suicidal like we talked about
call 1-800 uh the suicide number
but let me tell you something
[ __ ]
if you ain't suicidal and you ain't got
a gaming problem
download the draftking sportsbook app
now and use
code church and [ __ ] it if you're dying
your own money who gives a [ __ ]
they can't search you from the grave
yeah that's what are you john wayne
they went after [ __ ] john wayne
because he said [ __ ]
indian to 30 years ago he's been dead
for 18 [ __ ] thousand years
what are you gonna do to him he's in the
[ __ ] grave draftkings.com sportsbook
app
right now today draftking sports book
today [ __ ] what's it called
what's the thing church yeah download
draftking sports book now
and use code church and
all right draftkings that's the sports
book
of the united states not only new jersey
indiana and pennsylvania i love you guys
i want to thank the beautiful and
talented i love you
and next time we'll see you she'll be
married no
no no i want to get your dick sucked out
now
because kate's still available but not
really okay and
uh where do they go for your days i love
you uh you guys can just go to
katequigly.com or all my social media
okay and leah i love you [ __ ] and
you guys i'll see you monday don't
forget
we're on spotify i also want to give a
shout out to my little brother
his father got me into comedy the sheet
metal workers
of 104 my man jimmy jr handy up there
running [ __ ] things and don't forget
patreon.com
slash joey diaz a dollar oh that's it i
want a dollar that's
it don't send no more a dollar and we'll
get the party started from there
maybe in a month we'll start doing
[ __ ] uh great idea one joy night
videos i'll whack off for you i'll shave
my [ __ ] ass whole head
i'll shoot a bow and arrow at your
mother you know me i'll do anything for
a dollar
i love you guys have a great weekend lee
kick this [ __ ] meal tarzan
[Music]
you